okay let's get started it's my pleasure
to introduce Sergey 11 will be giving a
guest lecture today Sergey is an
assistant professor at UC Berkeley he
did his bachelor's and his PhD here at
Stanford University and his research is
at the intersection between control and
machine learning with the aim of
developing algorithms and techniques
that can endow machines with the ability
to autonomously acquire skills for
executing complex tasks and today he'll
be talking about information theoretic
exploration and unsupervised
reinforcement learning please join me in
welcoming Sergey thank you for the
introduction so yeah I thought a little
bit about what kind of topic to discuss
today and I figured I would actually
talk about something that's you know
addressing some challenges in
reinforcement learning but I think it
ties also pretty deeply to topics in
multi task learning and meta learning
that are serve the core focus of this
course so let's start off with a little
discussion of what's wrong with
reinforcement learning algorithms so you
guys had a few lectures on RL hopefully
you kind of have a decent idea of what
the basic setup looks like but you know
the basic set up has some issues so
here's an example of a task where you
have a little bipedal robot learning to
run and you might look at this and say
well that's that's pretty cool like this
little guy learned to run essentially
from scratch but what did it take for
him to get there well that learning
curve on the bottom shows the
progression the reward function is a
function of the number of time steps
that he have to actually attempt running
and if we put a scale on this in terms
of sort of hours of time that it would
take in the real world if it was like an
actual robot trying to run this little
bit where he just starts making progress
alone already takes ten hours and then
if you want to get to the end of this
curve over here this would be like on
the order of a hundred hours so pretty
cool that something is working but seems
like doing this from scratch takes a
really really long time and if you run
this algorithm twice you get two pretty
different solutions they both look like
reasonable running gates but something
here seems to be a little bit off if you
get totally different solutions each
time
and then you might also think well how
did we define the task for this little
guy in you know when we learn about
reinforced learning classically we're
told that we specify objectives or
reward functions that tell the system
what it's supposed to do and the
reinforcement learning algorithm tell is
supposed to figure out how to do it so
you might think well if you want it to
run then clearly you just give it a
reward function that says like you get a
1 if you run in a 0 otherwise go for it
and then you can figure the sound but of
course that's not how it works in
practice in practice if you actually use
a reward function like this you're not
going to get a very good solution and
what people do instead is they define
some complicated monster of a reward
function like this that says well have a
large forward velocity keep the torso
upright don't fall too much all this
other stuff does I should encode a
little bit more guidance about how the
task should be performed so long
training times different outcomes when
you run at different times complex
reward functions so there's a lot of
these challenges they're shot some of
these challenges are local Optima
challenges some of them are challenges
with needing to craft very detailed
reward functions and some of them are
challenges associated with long training
times and there are a variety of
different ways we can start thinking
about solving these challenges and I'm
going to discuss one perhaps somewhat
non-obvious direction which is to think
about you know how is it that that
humans and animals avoid having to deal
with some of these issues well maybe
part of the key to that is that we're
not actually you know this is very much
going to the core of this class we're
not really really learning all these
skills from scratch so in standard RL
settings you have very detailed goals
you're given that goal and you just try
to achieve that goal if you imagine that
you know a child interactive in this
environment maybe it doesn't have her
specific goals but it's interacting with
the world and acquiring knowledge about
the world through largely unstructured
interaction and now we might start
thinking well can this kind of
unstructured interaction help us address
these issues perhaps the issues
associated with local optima can be
mitigated by obtaining very good
coverage over the space of possible
behavior so that you know what's
possible in the world and then maybe
once you have that more global view of
the possibilities you can avoid the
local optimum when you're provided with
a specific task to accomplish perhaps
the need for detailed rewards can also
be alleviated by having some kind of
very diversity seeking exploration where
you see what all the possible things
that you can do
the world our and then maybe you can
deal with objectives that are as simple
as this because you've already seen
things that look a little bit like
running and a little bit like not
running and also maybe the long training
times can be alleviated by essentially
utilizing unstructured experience like
this as unsupervised pre training to
build up representations build up some
initial skills that can later be
utilized to address user specified goals
so the particular problem that I'm going
to talk about today is the the problem
of recovering diverse behavior without
access to any reward function and of
course I'll allude a little bit to how
this can be used to then achieve
specific goals later down the line but
I'll specific focus on the unsupervised
parts or the pre training part so this
part essentially why do we want this
well you might want it because you can
learn skills without supervision and
then use them to accomplish goals later
on you can learn sub skills and then use
those sub skills with hierarchical
reinforcement learning methods and you
can explore the space of possible
behaviors to help you later on get out
of those local ops so if you want kind
of a more concrete motivating example
scenario let's imagine that you buy your
you know mark one household robot and
this is your kitchen and you buy the
robot in the morning you put it in the
kitchen
and then you say you know do whatever it
is that you need to do to prepare
yourself for an unknown future goal and
then you're going to go to work and the
robot is going to go at it in your
kitchen trying to figure out what is it
that it can do and then you're gonna
come and come back in the evening and
you're gonna say well tonight your job
is going to be to do the dishes for me
and the robot should have done whatever
was necessary doing this unsupervised
pre-training phase to prepare it as well
as it possibly could for whatever
unknown task you might give it down the
line like doing the dishes that's sort
of an example scenario that we can keep
in our minds as I discuss some of the
techniques that we can think about for
those and you could you know if you're
willing to sort of stretch the analogy a
little bit you can also imagine that the
the child that was playing around with
toys on the previous slide was
unintentionally doing some variant of
this essentially exploring the world
with the unintentional aim of preparing
itself for whatever its future might
demand of it okay
so that's maybe the high level
motivation but the concrete things that
I'd like to discuss in today's lecture
I'm gonna start with some definitions
and concepts from information theory
that we're going to utilize repeatedly
in the lecture to actually think of
algorithms that can do this I'm going to
discuss a distribution matching
formulation of reinforcement learning
the deviates a little bit from the
standard way of formulating the
reinforced learning problem and provides
us a way to connect it with some of
these probabilistic concepts then I'll
talk about our first fully unsupervised
in reinforcement learning algorithm
we're just going to learn without a
reward function to reach diverse goals
and then I'll discuss a way that we can
extend this idea to match desired state
distributions talk about whether
coverage of state distributions is
actually a good exploration objective in
some theoretical sense and then
generalize the idea further from
covering the space of states to covering
the space of skills and then I'll
conclude by briefly tying these ideas
back to meta learning with a with a
short discussion about how some of these
unsupervised skill extraction techniques
can actually be utilized together with
with meta learning to perform
essentially unsupervised meta learning
you know and that'll be at the end of
the lecture I'm not sure if I'll get
through all of this but it sort of
depends on how many questions you guys
ask so feel free to ask questions if
you're if we were out of time this is
sort of intentionally designed so that
the most important stuff comes first
and sort of the fuzzier stuff comes
later all right
let's start with some definitions and
concepts and many of you might already
know a lot of these but I do want to go
through them so make sure we're all in
the same page so first some useful
identities hopefully all of you know
what a distribution is but we need to
know what a distribution is because
we're going to work a lot with
distributions so if this is your
variable X you can think of some getting
some samples represented by those blue
dots using those samples you can fit a
distribution it just tells you how dense
are your points in different regions now
a particular quantity that we can
compute on these distributions which is
going to be very useful for us in this
lecture is the entropy of the
distribution so I'm going to use this
script H to denote entropy entropy can
be defined like this you know it's this
equation might be a little bit
cryptic but to give you a little bit of
intuition about what's going on here
it's the negative of the expectation of
the law of probabilities so intuitively
if your distribution is very large log
probability somewhere then this
expectation will be large which means
that it's negative will be a very
negative number if the distribution has
very small log probabilities then this
expectation will also be small so it'll
be a less negative number so larger
entropy correspond to smaller log
probabilities which means that the
entropy quantifies in a sense how broad
the distribution is so if this
distribution is very wide it has large
entropy meaning it has small log
probabilities and if it's very peaked
then has a small entropy meaning large
log probabilities and this will be very
important in today's lecture the third
very useful identity is mutual
information
now again mutual information could be
defined as somewhat cryptic way but then
we can discuss it as so the intuition
behind it and that intuition will be
very useful for us so a mutual
information is a measure of how
intuitively how dependent two random
variables are and its definition as the
KL divergence between the Joint
Distribution of those variables P of X
comma Y and the prior to their marginals
be of X times P of Y which we can
equivalently write like this using the
definition of KL divergence but to
provide a little bit of intuition for
this let's say that you have two
different distributions over x and y
this top one here and this bottom one so
the green dots that i've plotted are
samples from that distribution so now
from looking at this definition can you
raise your hand if you think that the
top plot shows a distribution with
higher mutual information between x and
y now raise your hand if you think that
the lower one has higher mutual
information okay right so so the mutual
information is a measure of the deep of
the degree to which the variables are
dependent on each other high mutual
information means that x and y are
highly dependent low mutual information
means that they are largely independent
and very conveniently we can rewrite
mutual information as the difference of
two entropy the entropy of the marginal
of one of the variables so let's say the
entropy of P of Y minus the conditional
entropy of that variable conditioned on
the other one
and this has I think a very appealing
intuitive interpretation the second term
is very small it's a very small entropy
if when you know X you can accurately
guess Y so in this top plot you know Y
is roughly equal to X so if you know X
you can guess why pretty well in the
bottom plot y is independent of X so
knowing X doesn't help you guess why any
better but it's not enough for X for you
to be able to guess why from knowing X
you have to actually it has to actually
be difficult to guess Y so if Y is
always equal to 0.5 of course you can
guess why very accurately if you know X
but you can also guess it very accurate
if you don't know X so this first term
basically quantifies how hard it is to
guess why a priori if it's hard to guess
why I priori but much easier to guess Y
if you know X that means that X tells
you a lot about Y and that means that X
and y have high mutual information and
the reason I'm somewhat belaboring this
definition is because this intuition
will be very important later on to
understand what some of these own
supervisory and for some learning
algorithms are doing so as a little
let's go through of mutual information
in reinforcement learning let's say that
we have a distribution now our
distribution is going to be defined in
terms of quantities that we actually
care about in RL it's going to be
defined in terms of policies and States
so we'll say that PI of s is the state
marginal distribution of our policy PI
so you run your policy a whole bunch
count up which states at visits averaged
together those counts and you get a
distribution over States the entropy of
PI of s quantifies in a sense the
coverage of your policy so if your
policy has a very large entropy of PI of
s that means intuitively that it goes to
a wide range of different states that's
doing a good job of exploring now let's
think of an example of how we can use
mutual information to understand
something about
mdps here's an example of a mutual
information quantity called empowerment
I'm not actually gonna go through
empowerment in detail I just want to use
it as a short example so classically
empowerment is defined as the mutual
information between the next state s T
plus 1 and the current action a T on the
surface this might at first seem like a
slightly cryptic con
but let's go back to those the
difference of entropies definition from
the previous slide we know that we can
write this mutual information as the
entropy of s T plus 1 minus the entropy
of s T plus 1 given a T so that means
that if you know what action you took
you can guess your next state very
accurately if you don't know what action
you took you cannot guess your next
state very accurately what that means is
that you go to a wide range of different
states and your actions are very
predictive of those states so now let's
think about that a little bit why would
we call something like this empowerment
it sounds like a very lofty term any
guesses about why this is called
empowerment yes
exactly yeah it's it measures the amount
of control authority you have over your
world if your actions are highly
predictive of your States that means
your actions are influencing your States
in a fairly predictable way so that
means that you have a lot of control
about what goes on if if these two
entropy x' are equal that means that
your actions have no effect on the state
that means that you're sort of enfeebled
you're not able to affect the world
around you so that's why it's called a
empowerment so anyway that's just a
little exercise to help us think about
mutual information in the context of
control problems let's talk about the
first kind of algorithmic component
today's lecture which is how we can
reformulate classic reinforcement
learning as a distribution matching
problem in this case it'll be a
distribution matching problem on actions
so I'll first motivate this a little bit
with a with an actual challenge that we
sometimes face in RL so this is the
challenge that I showed on that first
slide you take your favorite RL
algorithm this particular one is T RPO
you run it twice and you get two
different answers and you think what the
hell just happened well you can set up a
little toy problem that captures sort of
a microcosm of this issue because it's a
little hard to reason about these
complicated humanoids so let's set up
something much simpler let's say we have
four legs instead of two because that's
clearly simpler and we're navigating a
little maze and our goal is to reach
this Blue Square now when you're first
starting out you can explore the upper
passage or the lower passage and both at
first seem like you're making progress
towards the goal
so if you make it a little further along
the upper passage think oh I'm getting
closer I'm getting closer let's just go
there but then you get the stuck so
intuitively the right strategy for a
problem like this ought to be to explore
both passages in roughly equal
proportion until you figure out that one
of them is decisively better than the
other and I would actually posit that
the issue here is very much like the
issue here that reinforcement learning
it's self reinforcing once you see that
you're making a little bit more progress
along the upper passage classic
reinforcement learning algorithms will
want to commit all the probability mass
there because they're getting larger
rewards there in the same way that this
little running guy as soon as he figures
out one type of running gate he'll want
to go more to that place and ignore all
other possible gates because that one
running gate where he randomly made a
little more progress is the one that
seems to be more rewarding that's a
local optimal problem so how can we
attract both hypotheses or in general
all hypotheses that are valuable to us
so we're going to talk a lot about Q
functions many of you might already know
what Q functions are but a short primer
in RL you have actions you have States
and you have rewards your goal is to
maximize your expected reward under your
policy so hopefully we're all good with
that and the Q function is defined as
the expected value of the rewards that
you will accumulate if you start in
state s take the action a and then
afterwards follow your policy pi and
reward functions are very useful because
if you have I was right
q functions are very useful because if
you have a q function for a policy you
can extract a better policy simply by
being greedy with respect to your q
function so if you take an action with
probability 1 if that action is the arc
max of your Q function you know that
this policy will be at least as good as
the one that you use to train your Q
function and of course from this you can
get a reinforcement learning algorithm
the one that I outlined here is policy
iteration you can also directly enforce
optimality on the Q function by forcing
your your Q flexure to obey this
equation so if you can enforce this
equation everywhere then you'll just
recover the optimal Q function directly
so that's Q learn okay so yeah this is
basically the only equation you know for
the Q learning algorithm so we can do
something like Q learning for our little
with the two passages and let's say that
initially we make a little bit more
progress along this upper passage if we
make a little bit more progress along
the upper passage then the height of
this cue function will be a little
larger it'll it'll take on slightly
larger values for the four going left
here and that's a problem because if the
way that we're going to improve our
policies by taking the Arg max then our
policy will then put all this
probability mass on this better option
this option is not actually better it
just looks better because we've got
lucky but as soon as we get lucky once
we'll go there even more which means
that we'll get even luckier until
eventually we're completely committing
ourselves to exploring this upper
passage without you and having seen
what's going on down here so that's no
good what we can do instead is we could
imagine committing our probability mass
in proportion to some positive
transformation of our cue function so
that if the Q values for two options
look about equally good we'll explore
them about equally often and it turns
out that a very convenient positive
transformation to use is the exponential
we'll see why in a second but
intuitively if we choose our policy to
not be the greedy policy but to commit
probability mass in proportion to the
exponential of the Q values then two
options that have roughly equal Q values
will be explored to about equal degrees
and we won't necessarily have this
problem of immediately committing to the
first option that accidentally looks a
little bit better so why is it so
convenient to use an exponential well
because it allows us to bring in some of
those concepts from information theory
it turns out that if you write down the
KL divergence between your policy PI and
the exponential of the q function so you
can treat this as a probability
distribution if you normalize it and
then by the definition of KL divergence
this is equal to the expectation under
PI of Q minus log pi and this is now
starting to look an awful lot like
regular reinforcement learning this
first term is basically your expected
reward because remember that Q is the
expectation of future rewards so that
means that this first term turns into
the expectation under PI of your future
rewards this second term that's the new
guy that's something that we didn't have
in regular RL but the expectation under
PI of log pi is just the entropy so all
we've done if we
our objective to the scale divergence is
we've taken our regular RL objective and
added the entropy of Pi to it we call
this the maximum entropy objective
because what it tells us to do is to
maximize our rewards while at the same
time being as random as possible and
this actually allows us to address this
problem with the two passages why well
because if you're maximizing your
rewards while being as random as
possible that means that when you have
two roughly equally good options you
should take both options in equal
proportion because that will give you
higher entropy than committing to one of
the two once you're sure that one of the
two options is much much better then
it's fine to commit all your probability
mass to that but if they look about
equally good you should try both and
that will allow you to maximize your
entropy so it's a distribution matching
objective in the sense that pi is
matching this exponential Q distribution
and it allows us to begin addressing
this local optima issue now building on
this idea we can do lots of fancy math
so for those of you that are that like
concepts like variational inference you
can actually show that this kind of
objective emerges from a particular kind
of inference problem so in optimal
control or reinforcement learning we ask
the question which actually lead to an
optimal future which actual maximize
your reward that's a very reasonable
question to ask in inference you could
imagine asking a slightly different
question but you anything are ending up
with a very similar answer which is
given that your future is optimal which
action would you have taken turns out
that the answer that second question is
basically exactly that maximum entropy
objective so if we're going to talk
about inference of course we need to ask
inference in what model so we're going
to build up a graphical model a
probabilistic graphical model that we
can use for max and entropy
reinforcement learning in this graphical
model we're going to have states and
actions
that's that should be familiar to all of
you that's basically how the sequential
decision-making process works what we
all seem to somehow introduce our
rewards and the way that will introduce
our rewards at first looks a little
peculiar but it actually is going to
make a lot of sense so we're going to
introduce these additional auxilary
variables that I'm going to call o for
optimality these variables are not equal
to rewards they're actually binary
variables and our evidence is that those
variables are all true that is to say
our evidence is that you are being
optimal
given that you are being optimal what
action are you taking and we're going to
define the probability of those
variables being true as the exponential
of the reward you need a slight
regularity condition for this to make
sense which is that your award needs to
always be negative because you can't
have you know probabilities that are
larger than one but except for that
regularity condition this is a
well-defined probablistic graphical
model so now the question that you want
to answer is what's the probability of
an action given your current state and
given that you are always being optimal
so given that you are rational how
likely is a certain action and if we set
up this inference problem we can
actually do basically the usual thing
that we do we can do some variant of
variable elimination so I'll walk
through this pretty quickly there will
be lots of equations but I promise you
that they're actually pretty simple
equations so we need to write down the
distribution which we're doing inference
so it's a distribution over all of our
states and actions because we don't know
what those are going to be given our
evidence which is that these optimality
variables are true we have three types
of conditional probability distributions
in this model the initial state p of s 0
our optimality variable probabilities
exponential of r and the transition
probabilities P of s T plus 1 you have
an S dat
we're going to take this joint and then
we're going to compute the conditional
that we want which is P of a T given s T
comma R evidence so that's the thing
that we want and the way that we're
going to do this is going to be using
variational inference because s is an
A's are continuous huge so doing this
inference exactly is intractable but
variational and first give us a nice
optimization based way to solve this
inference problem and requires us to
define a variational distribution
remember that a variational distribution
is just a distribution over all of our
hidden variables that has some
convenient form that makes inference
easy usually we choose the variational
distribution to be something really
simple like a product of independent
marginals here I'm going to make a very
peculiar choice for my variational
distribution I'm going to choose it such
that it looks a lot like my original
distribution usually if you're doing
variational inference this is not a very
good idea because the whole point of
doing a variational inference is to use
a simpler variational family than your
original model but it turns out that in
this very
very special case this will lead to a
very convenient solution so the way that
I'm going to define my very shrill
distribution is by using the same
initial state probabilities the same
transition probabilities and then I'm
going to the only thing that I'm
actually gonna say that's different is
PI of a given s so up here I had this
exponential R here I have the PI so
that's my variational family this is
just a picture of the of the virtual
distribution so we have this additional
edge from s to a and you no longer have
the O's because that's your evidence and
we don't put evidence in our variational
distributions so now the variational
lower bound which is what we optimized
move to variational inference it's
simply the KL divergence between Q and P
if you don't believe me you can do a
little bit of algebra I promise you this
this is in fact a correct way to write
the variational lower bound and being a
KL divergence you can express it as
simply the expectation under Q of log Q
minus log P and this is where the
cleverness is going to come in the
reason that we chose our Q in this very
peculiar way is that now we're going to
get lots and lots of cancellation if we
actually substitute it in our definition
of Q and a definition of P into here we
get a huge huge equation almost all of
which cancels if you're wondering what I
did here is I just put the log of these
in here and log of products as sum of
logs so that's where all this stuff
comes from and of course because I chose
the P of s 0 here to match the one here
that cancels out the transition
probabilities cancel out so the only
terms that remain are the log PI's and
the rewards and this is all in
expectation under Q which is this thing
so that's just equal to the sum over all
my time steps of the expectation of R
plus the entropy of Pi which is exactly
what we had on the previous slide when
we talked about maximum entropy
reinforcement learning so maximum
entropy reinforcement learning its
objective is exactly the variation of
lower bound for this particular
variational approximation which means
that we are in fact doing approximate
inference in this graphical model that's
pretty neat that means that our
reinforcement learning procedure now
actually corresponds to probe list ik
inference now how do we actually
optimize that variational lower bound
well you have a few choices
choice is to just use policy gradient
policy grading is great because you can
just write down your objective calculate
its derivatives and then do grading
ascent and it'll work it'll take a huge
number of samples but it'll work if you
want to be a little more clever you can
actually modify q-learning to optimize
this objective it turns out to look like
a procedure that greatly resembles
message-passing so how do you modify
q-learning to optimize a subjective I'm
not going to prove this I'm just gonna
state the result but you can look up the
you know the explanation for why this is
true in this tutorial so regular cue
learning performs updates like this so
reward plus the max over the next cue
that's the cue learning algorithm that
we all learn from Richard Sutton's
textbook or whatever first reinforcement
in class you took if you want to modify
cue learning to solve this inference
problem all you do is you replace this
max with a seemingly cryptic log of the
integral of an exponential this first at
first this seems like a really bizarre
thing to do
what's a log of an integral of an
exponential but imagine for a second
that your Q values are very very big if
your Q values are very very big when you
exponentiate them the biggest of them
dominates all the rest when you sum them
all together that sum isn't entirely
dominated by the exponential of the
biggest value so we can take the log you
essentially get back the biggest value
so if your Q values are very big then
the log of the integral of the
Exponential's is very close to a max and
that makes a lot of sense because if
we're matching distributions if we're
doing this Maxim thing and we have one
choice that is extremely large and all
other choices are extremely bad then
we'll just put all our mouse there and
then we'll do a max but if all our
choices are about equally good then we
want to put a probability Mouse on all
of them and then we have a very soft max
here that looks small so all you do is
your regular Q learning except instead
of a max you use the log of the integral
of Exponential's and then you will
actually optimize this maximum entropy
RL problem and then you will do this
nice distribution matching a modern
algorithm that instantiates this basic
idea in more of a policy iteration
framework Roth
Hieu learning framework was called soft
actor critic some of you probably heard
about soft doctor critic in Kiev or
Kelly's lecture and actually soft actor
critic in fact solves that same
inference problem so it consists of
primarily two steps there's a cue
function update which updates the cue
function for a given policy so this is
not a Q star update this is a QP update
and the only modification there is to
incorporate that entropy term the log pi
so this will convert to q pi for a given
policy under the maximum entropy
objective and then there's a policy
update step which is basically that KL
divergence the max and RL the KL
divergence objective Gail Devers between
PI and this Q function and of course in
practice you do the usual actor critic
thing which means you take one radiance
step on this one gradient step on that
and then repeat but if it's a proper
policy iteration procedure you would
actually run this thing to convergence
and then run this thing to convergence
and then you interact with the world
collect more data sort of usual RL thing
turns out that the Q function update is
essentially doing message passing in
your graphical model and the policy
update is fitting that variational
distribution so they actually correspond
to parts of a well-defined inference
procedure this algorithm works decently
well so it gets good results on a bunch
of benchmark tasks but maybe more
interestingly it actually exhibits some
interesting properties that might
suggest that it could alleviate some of
these issues that I outline on the first
slide of the lecture for example you can
use a soft actor critic or in general
soft optimality algorithm like soft
q-learning to pre train policies that
can then be fine-tuned or more narrow
objectives this is not fully
unsupervised pre-screening yet that will
come later but it's sort of starting to
get at that idea so one of the things
you can do is you can train a policy for
this little quadrupedal and robot with a
reward function that says run as fast as
possible now let's think about this for
a minute if your reward function is just
the norm of your velocity and you run
regular reinforcement learning what will
it do
well it'll pick a direction arbitrarily
and we'll run in that direction
if you're doing knocks on entropy
reinforcement learning our objective is
to maximize our reward while being as
random as possible so let's let's
imagine for a second what that would do
with an objective that just says
maximize the norm of your velocity okay
so if you've all thought about it let's
see what it actually does so this is the
soft Q learning method there it goes
it's a Halloween special
it's a fright it's of this frightening
explosion of spiders but once you get
over the initial scare you'll notice
that it's actually running in
essentially a distribution of possible
directions so it tries to run it doesn't
in as many directions as possible
because by doing that it can maximize
entropy now why is this useful other
than you know you know scaring people
you can take this thing and you can fine
tune it with a specific direction so you
can Prague's that will put it into a
hallway and then we're gonna fine tune
it to run down this hallway so you'll
see this one is initialized randomly
this one is initialized with
deterministic RL and this one is
initialized with maximum entropy RL the
initialization from the specific RL
knows how to run in one specific
arbitrary direction which is almost
certainly not the direction of this
hallway because you know it's extremely
unlikely that was the one that picked
during pre training the maximum entropy
one knows how to run in all possible
directions so all that has to do is just
unlearn all the wrong directions and
just keep going in the right direction
so that allows the max and
initialization to learn a lot more
quickly in practice and of course if we
look at the plots that's pretty much
what we see so the blue lines show fine
tuning for the max and initialization
and the green lines show fine tuning for
the deterministic reinforcement learning
algorithm okay I'll probably skip over
the hierarchical policies and I do want
to get more to the fun unsupervised
stuff but maybe I'll briefly show some
of the robot videos as a little
intermission
so besides generating videos with
exploding spiders we can use this to
actually train robots to do interesting
tasks in the real world so this is a
soft Q learning experiment where we use
soft Q learning to train this soya robot
to stack a Lego block
we weren't so much interested in whether
or not I could stack the Lego block I
mean we we know how to do this part this
is not that difficult what we wanted to
see is whether the injection of that
entropy maximization resulted in
interesting behavior at test time so we
did a test time of courses that we went
in and we messed with it we went in and
we perturb the robot to try to see how
well it could react to our perturbations
the reason that it can react to those
perturbations is because during training
you're maximizing entropy which means
that you're essentially teaching the
policy to be resilient to as much
injective noise as possible you can do
this on other kinds of robots too this
is a this is actually soft actor critic
running on a quadrupedal robot that is
trying to learn how to walk so initially
the robot doesn't know anything so it
sort of Wiggles around randomly and then
after some time passes it begins making
forward progress
this basically learns in about two hours
how to walk forward and once learning is
concluded then you can run the robot and
it has a pretty decent pretty plausible
gait and then again you can start
messing with it and see how much the
entropy injection during training
actually helped it acquire robust
strategies of course they've never seen
slopes like this before so it struggles
a little bit and you can if you give it
a large enough perturbation it will
eventually fail there has some degree of
robustness so I can walk down stairs I
can't I should walk up stairs that will
fail but can go down stairs and it can
very poorly play Jenga so there we go so
that's the that's maximum entropy RL now
maximum entropy RL is not yet
unsupervised reinforcement learning we
still have to give it a reward function
but subject reward function it was
learning a breadth of different
behaviors next we're going to talk about
how we can actually learn without any
reward function at all so let's think
back to the scenario you buy your
household robot you put it in your
kitchen you turn it on and you let it
work for a whole day and you come back
in the evening and you give it a goal
and it's supposed to do something during
this day that best prepares us for the
goal that you're going to give it so
what can I do well before we talk about
what it's going to do during during its
day well it's actually first
fast-forward and talk about what's going
to happen in the evening in the evening
you need to give it an objective and
that means that you need an interface
let's nail down a very simple interface
let's say they're gonna show it a state
that you wanted to reach so if it's
doing things using my camera images then
maybe what you're gonna show it is an
image if it's doing things using you
know a vector of states of all the
objects in the world and you're getting
you're going to give it a desire to
vector of states of objects in the world
so you're going to give it a goal state
does I'm not necessarily going to claim
this as a good interface it's just a
simple one that allows us to get started
it's a little weird to you know task
your Allah by giving it a photograph of
the desired outcome but at least it's
simple and we can all understand it so
if that's the interface we're gonna use
then somewhere under the hood your
friendly robot needs to be able to
compare two states it needs to look at
this picture and it needs to look at
this picture and tell you how similar
they are to each other there are a
variety of ways to do this but the way
that we were gonna try to do it is by
building a latent variable model whose
latent variables are a little bit more
meaningful than the original observation
space so if you compare the pixels in an
image the the resulting distance doesn't
really correspond to like the physical
proximity of two states but maybe you
can embed those images into some
late-late in space where distances are
meaningful and you have a variety of
choices for how to do this
Gans will do this we're going to use
something called variational
autoencoders just another latent
variable model and there are many
choices and then we're going to use the
latent space of that variational auto
encoder to compare two states and then
since we actually have this latent
variable model the way that we're gonna
get the robot to practice during the day
is by generating samples from that
latent variable model so the robot has a
model that can sample from that model
can essentially hallucinate potential
images set those as goals for itself and
then go on practice reaching them that
makes a lot of sense I think you know
that this is a plausible way to practice
goals but there's a pretty substantial
problem with this up does anyone have
any ideas about what problem we might
have if we go and do this
right so one answer is that it might it
might set easy goals for itself where is
the latent variable model going to come
from we have to train it on data there's
only one source of data it's the robot
so it's going to use its own experience
to Train that latent variable model
maybe he did some random useless stuff
maybe it broke the dishes now it has
lots of data of breaking dishes so it'll
generate more goals of breaking dishes
and I'll just keep going in a loop
essentially doing the thing that is done
successfully before setting those easy
goals so that's no good what we need is
we need some way to encourage it to
diversify so let's first sort of outline
this algorithm a little bit more
precisely we have our variational auto
encoder that variational auto encoder
has a decoder distribution but I'm going
to call P theta X given Z so X is your
state or image and Z is your latent
variable it has a prior P of Z so if you
wanted to sample your first sample Z
from P of Z and then X from a P theta X
given Z and it also has an encoder q Phi
Z given s sorry Z given X that should be
Z given X it's a little typo and the way
that your training is going to proceed
is that you're going to propose a goal
how do you propose a goal while you
sample from your VSO sample z from P of
Z sample X from P of X given Z then
you're going to attempt to reach that
goal
using your policy so your policy now is
PI of a given X comma X G so it's going
to sharing your current state and the
goal so you're gonna learn this giant
policy that will attempt to reach all
possible goals of course your policy in
general will not necessarily succeed it
won't reach that goal perfectly it'll
reach some other state x bar and if it's
a very good policy the next bar will be
very similar to X G if it's a very bad
policy the next bar will be some random
thing and then you're gonna learn you're
going to use your data to update your
policy and you're going to use your data
to update your ve which means you're
gonna change P theta and Q Phi now of
course in practice the way that we would
implement this is we would use a replay
buffer so when you attempt to reach the
goal you just add this to your buffer
and then you use all of your data so far
to update your policy and your via e but
for now let's for simplicity let's think
of this as an online
algorithm no we'll just keep things a
little simple and then of course you
repeat so this easy goals problem
happens because we use this data that we
actually obtain from this policy to
update our goal proposer which will then
propose more goals that look like the
states we reached and we'll start going
in a circle and not actually do anything
interesting so intuitively what we'd
like to do is we'd like to up weight
those goals that seem more interesting
to us so if your robot lives in a 2d
environment and these little circles
denote the states that had visited if
you have a big clump of stuff over here
and you have these really rare things
that you reached out on the fringes and
totally what you'd like to do is to
somehow up wait these rare things and do
those more often because those are
probably the harder the more interesting
goals so maybe if you somehow up weight
them and then fit your model and then
propose from that model when you then go
to reach those goals you might actually
end up putting more mass onto the tails
of your distribution and gradually
expand and we'll make this very vague
notion a little bit more precise later
so in order to do something like that
all we really have to do is we have to
modify this last step because step four
is the step that actually uses your data
to change which goals will be proposed
in the future and we need to modify step
four so that if the state x-bar that you
reached was very interesting it should
get a bigger weight and if it was very
boring it should get a smaller weight
now interesting and boring here means is
it a state that you've reached often or
the state that you've reached rarely so
that's this step here's how you can do
it standard maximum likelihood
estimation will basically train your VA
EE to maximize some approximation to the
log likelihood of X bar now if it's a VA
e you're actually using a variational
lower bound to approximate this because
you can't evaluate log P of X bar
exactly but some approximation to log P
of X bar weighted maximum likelihood
estimation exactly as the name might
imply we'll just put a little multiplier
on this and this multiplier some
function of X bar and by choosing that
multiplier carefully we can actually
create this effect where
the interesting or rare outcomes are up
waited and the uninteresting or common
outcomes are down waited all we do is we
use our previous density estimator our p
theta x bar or some approximation
thereof raised to some power alpha where
alpha is between negative 1 and zero so
it's basically going to be its it the
weight is smaller for larger
probabilities to wait our likelihood so
that means that if a particular X bar is
extremely probable it's in this really
dense region then when you raise it to
the power let's say negative 0.5 it'll
get a much smaller weight if it's very
rare it's probabilities like zero point
zero zero zero zero one but then you
raise it to some negative power and get
a really big weight so that'll do
exactly what we want it will up weight
these things in the tails and the
interesting result that you can prove
which is described in the second paper
de la langue Lin at all is that for any
alpha between negative one and zero
following this procedure actually
increases the entropy of P theta of X
now if you increase the entropy every
single step and you can prove that it
doesn't asymptote of something
suboptimal and eventually you get full
entropy you get the highest entropy
distribution that you can have and the
highest entropy distribution that you
can have is the uniform distribution
over all valid states question right so
the question was at each step why don't
just uniformly sample from the state
space if you could uniform a sample from
the state space that would be a better
algorithm the trouble that we have is
that our observations or our states here
in these X's they might be for example
images from the robots camera uniformly
sampling images by itself doesn't
actually produce uniformly sampled valid
States because most random images are
kind of static their white noise so what
you want is you want uniformly sampled
valid States and that can be a really
complex manifold in the space of all
possible X vectors so essentially we can
view this procedure as a really fancy
way of discovering that uniform
distribution any other questions ok
so now we have we've defined how the
step is going to work we just use this w
which is which comes from using our
previous density estimator and now we
can ask the question what is the
objective for this procedure so we kind
of cooked up this recipe but what is
this recipe doing is it actually
optimizing some well-defined objective
and that's where things get a little bit
interesting so if you're entropy
increases every step you can actually
show that under a few additional
conditions what you're actually
optimizing is the entropy of your goal
distribution so this P of G this is the
distribution of your goals which are
coming from your ve so you're increasing
that entropy so you're maximizing that
entropy and you can show that this is
actually true but that's not all that
you're doing you're not just training a
VA you're also training a policy so your
goals get higher entropy due to this
skew fit procedure but what does RL do
well your policy PI and I'm gonna
rewrite it as PI of a given s comma G
just to make it very explicit but
there's a state and there's a goal it's
being trained to reach goals and if it
does a very good job of reaching those
goals then it will reach a state its
final state s that is close to the goal
in fact it might even be equal to the
goal so what that means is that as your
policy gets better and better it becomes
easier and easier to predict what the
goal was from looking at the state that
it reached so if the policy is very good
if it always reaches the goal then G is
equal to s so P of G given s is a very
low entropy distribution now where are
we seen that before we're making one
entropy big and we're making some
conditional and should be small so if
that's our objective that's actually
exactly the mutual information between s
and G and that's kind of cool somehow we
had this kind of cooked up procedure
involving ves and maximizing entropy
xand and up weighting things and all
that turns into is just the mutual
information between the last state that
you're reaching your trajectory and your
goal and if you maximize that mutual
information then you end up successfully
reaching a wide range of goals
so maximize mutual information between s
and G leads to a good exploration
because you're trying to make this first
entropy term big and it leads to
effective goal reaching because you're
trying to make that second and should be
small and of course there are other ways
to approximate that mutual information
of which the sacrum is just one of them
any questions about this okay
again I'm contractually obligated to
show your robot videos so we ran this
thing on a robot and therefore we have
to show this to you at zero hours so
that what does this robot doing first of
all it's it's a robotic arm it's placed
in front of a door you might think that
it's told to open the door it's not told
to open the door is just placed in front
of the door but that's a very suggestive
way to set up your robot so of course
initially what it's going to do is is
going to wiggle its hand a little bit
because that's the most obvious thing to
do for an untrained reinforcement
learning algorithm but pretty quickly it
figures out that hand wiggling results
in images that have a high probability
under its V AE and it starts proposing
all sorts of other goals that involve
actually interacting with the door
because that allows it to achieve
outcomes that have a low probability
under its ve and then their probability
increases and it opens the door to all
sorts of different angles and then at
the end once it's all trained it can
actually open this door to any angle
that you want without actually being
told in advance that door opening is
what you're supposed to do so you can
think of this as a very very limited
version of that household robot where
it's not placed in a messy kitchen it's
placed in this admittedly rather
pristine laboratory setting but maybe a
step in the right direction and you can
test it and you can give a different
goal States so here a person is actually
giving it pictures and we're just
testing to make sure that it can open
the door to every desired angle all
right so that was learning with goals
now the next thing to talk about is kind
of a state distribution matching
formulation of reinforcement learning
that generalizes these ideas a little
bit further so remember before I talked
about this next symmetric brl thing
which matches action distributions and I
also talked about how we can maximize
the entropy of possible goals
so can we somehow combine these ideas to
match state distribution so instead of
just making your state distribution as
broad as possible can you say match a
distribution in state space rather than
an action space and it's potentially
quite useful because then you can go and
explore diverse states under a prior
over good States so if so maybe your
household robot needs to be told in
advance I don't care about states where
my dishes are broken I don't care about
states where you know you threw my Vaz
out the window but all the other states
knows I care about so do everything
except for breaking my dishes and
throwing stuff out the window and then
you're gonna have a much more coherent
exploration strategy so before I
describe how to do this as an aside let
me describe something that does not
solve this problem it might seem like it
solves this problem but it doesn't and
there's something called intrinsic
motivation so this is a common method
for doing exploration in non
information-theoretic settings you
incentivize your policy PI of a given us
to explore diverse States before it sees
any reward and the way that you do it is
by rewarding visiting states that are
novel this will at first seem like it's
very very similar to I discussed before
but it actually leads to very different
outcomes so if a state is visited often
it's not novel if a state is visited
rarely than it is a novel and the way
that we do this this is kind of very
standard reward bonus exploration is by
adding a little term to our reward
function based on the negative log P PI
of s so you estimate how often your
policy visits each your state and
subtract those log probabilities from
your reward and that'll get your policy
to receive larger rewards for states
that have visited rarely so you update
your policy to maximize this expected
the expected value of this modified
reward update your P PI update your
estimate of the state marginal and then
repeat and what does this do well let's
say that initially your policy does this
you fit your state distribution you get
this green circle it's a little faint on
the slide but there's a little old green
circle that I drew around this thing
so then anything inside that green
circle gets a lower reward because in a
higher probability everything outside
that circle gets a higher reward because
there's lower probability so what does
the policy do well it goes somewhere
else
and then your distribution changes and
then it goes somewhere else and so on so
your policy does end up going to lots of
different places but at any given point
in time your policy is not actually
covering the space it's just going to
some arbitrary location it'll go
somewhere else next time so this
distribution keeps chasing chasing your
policy and your policy keeps changing at
no instant in time do external policy
that covers the space so it kind of
seems like it's very close to the right
answer
but it's not quite the right answer
there's something missing so can we fill
in this missing piece can we somehow
change this intrinsic motivation method
so that it actually matches a desired
state distribution it turns out that
it's not actually that hard so the state
marginal matching problem is to learn a
policy PI so as to minimize the KL
divergence between that policy state
marginal and a desired state marginal so
you have a target density and our idea
is to somehow utilize the centric
motivation principle so we're going to
define our reward function as log of our
desired probability minus the log of our
current probability so this is starting
to look a lot like Gail Devers it's all
starting look a lot like intrinsic
motivation now this by itself doesn't
yet perform marginal matching because
your policy keeps getting chased around
like this your policy never actually
ends up matching the distribution but
it's very close so the procedure is you
learn your PI K and I'm intentional
going to put this superscript K to
denote the policy iteration K to
maximize the expected value of your
reward our K so our K means that the
peopie is actually P PI K you update
your distribution to fit the state
marginal to get P PI K plus 1 and then
you repeat and let's say this orange
circle is my desire to distribution so
by itself my policy will sort of try to
escape from my distribution and it'll
keep getting chased around and never
actually match the thing so what if
instead we update our distribution P PI
K to fit all
state seen so far so that'll take care
of one side of the problem because now
we're actually and we're not just
matching the distribution from the
current policy of mashing distribution
from all policies and then what we
return at the end is not the last PI K
but the mixture of all the policies seen
so far because remember these policies
were running all over the state space it
went here and one there and one there
no one policy covers the space but the
ensemble of all policies together does
actually cover the space and that's not
actually just a vague intuition it turns
out that you can actually show that this
ends up being the Nash equilibrium for a
two-player game where one player is
trying to basically optimize this
objective and the other one is trying to
match the distribution this is a
technique called self play or sometimes
referred as historical averaging where
if you're optimizing these objectives in
alternating fashion the way that you
actually recover the equilibrium which
has to be a stochastic policy is by
averaging together the iterates so this
is just like a theorem that you can look
up very simple modification to intrinsic
motivation turns out to action national
distributions so it's a game between the
two players the players are PI K and P
PI K and of course there's a special
case of this where if you choose P star
to be a constant meaning the uniform
distribution then you're just maximizing
state entropy and then and then you
recover the algorithm from a previous
section okay so does this work the
answer is that it basically does so this
is a comparison between soft actor
critic which is a maximum entropy
reinforcement learning algorithm that
Nash's action distributions versus the
state marginal matching method which
matches state distributions and this is
a heat map visualizing this little quote
repeated robot running around in this
little funny world with three hallways
and you can see that the heat map of
State marginal matching is much more
uniform this is trying to actually
uniform distribution I'll skip over this
here it's trying to match kind of a
funny lopsided distribution so it's
trying to move this little block to
different places and we tell it we
wanted the left side to be twice as
likely as the right side now of course
matches perfectly the red line is the
state marginal mastering because that's
to contend with the dynamics of the real
world so you can't go to the left side
without passing through at least a
little bit of the right right side but
you can see that it's like a little bit
more skewed to the left so it's a lot
more probability mass on the left side a
lot less on the right side so kind of
seems to be doing something all right
but maybe the next question that I want
to ask and this is an important question
is is this actually a good way to
explore like intuitive they kind of make
sense you want to see lots of different
things in the world so you want to get
good coverage so you're going to
maximize your state entropy he's
actually a good idea to maximize state
entropy so state and should be really a
good objective and if it's a good
objective what is it a good objective
for so you know just to sort of recap
what we saw before the skew fit does
this you know mutual information between
states and goals which corresponds to
maximizing goal entropy and minimizing
goal given state entropy state marginal
matching in the special case where you
choose P star to be a constant also
maximize a state entropy so seems like
this is something we kind of know how to
do they're more or less the same thing
but when is this a good idea so one
place where it's a good idea I'm gonna
local call this isin box theorem it's
not actually a theorem it's just been
Eisenbach was the one who who told me
about it but it's a it follows trivially
from a classic maximum entropy modelling
the result so don't take the the name or
the fact that I call it a theorem two
seriously it says that if at test time
an adversary will choose the worst goal
meaning that when you come home after
letting your robot run all day you know
what your robot is good at and going to
choose the worst possible thing you're
like the world's worst robot owner if
that's what you're going to do then the
then the best goal distribution to use
for training is actually the one with
the largest entropy so if the robot
knows you're going to be the worst
possible robot owner then the optimal
thing for that robot to do without any
other knowledge about what kind of goal
you might propose is to maximize the
entropy of goals and this follows
directly from the equivalence between
symmetric remodeling and the the
adversarial formulation where you
maximize P and minimize Q so if you if
you read about maximum entropy models
it's just basically a trivial corollary
to that so if you want to read a little
bit more about this idea its summarized
in this paper called unsupervised meta
learning for reinforcement learning
which I'll come back to later but the
short version is that there is actually
a kind of a principal reason to suppose
that maximizing state entropy is good
because it makes you robust in the face
of the worst case human so to speak and
another actually excellent paper to read
about some theoretical reasons why high
static it might be a good idea is this
paper called provably efficient maximum
entropy exploration by has on at all so
if you're interested in some of the
theoretical foundations for this I
highly recommend that paper okay so the
the next kind of algorithmic idea I want
to discuss a little bit it's how we can
go a little bit beyond just covering
states and actually think about covering
the space of possible skills so so far
all of the unsupervised are elegans
we've talked about they are attempting
to reach goals or reach states maximize
standard trapeze that sort of thing
but there's more to behavior than just
reaching States so next i'm gonna talk
about learning diverse skills so a skill
you know I'm going to define skill in a
very peculiar way don't take this kind
of too seriously but I just need a term
for so I'm going to call it a skill I'm
gonna have a policy pie that gives a
distribution of our actions condition on
States and condition over the on the Z
before this was a goal but now there's
going to be a task index
what's a task index it's an integer it's
gonna be like 0 1 2 3 and intuitively if
you want diverse skills then what you
want this pie to do is you want to go to
2 to go and do different things for
different values of Z so maybe if you
give it a Z of 0 you should you should
have it like go up here if you give it a
Z of one it should go over here as you
have to it should go there so basically
the different Z's should do different
things ok that kind of makes sense
now why can't you just do this with
maximum entropy reinforcement learning
or that goal reaching thing well so
maximum entropy RL it just does action
entropy action entropy is not the same
as covering the space of skills so
you'll take different actions but you
might actually up in very similar places
from taking very different actions so
that's not quite what we want you can
take different actions - similar States
reaching diverse goals is not the same
as performing diverse tasks either and
that that's a little bit more subtle the
reason for this is that not all
behaviors can be captured by goal
reaching let me give you an example the
behavior that cannot be captured by goal
reaching this is my favorite quadrupedal
robot it needs to go to this green
location and it needs to avoid this red
thing at all costs so maybe the red
thing is the is the fire pit of death
that's where you're not allowed to go
the green thing is your is your favorite
object in the world if you just try to
reach this green state then you'll go
straight through the the bad red thing
so you cannot frame this as a pure goal
reaching problem now this task can still
be defined in terms of states is just
that now the state distribution that you
want is more complicated there are some
states that you want to not land and in
some other states you want to land in as
often as possible and then to go back to
the max sense stuff you know the max
scent IRL policies are stochastic but
they're not always controllable so they
they you know if you remember that the
and running in all possible directions
we couldn't really tell it which
direction to run it just randomly runs
in random directions here we want
something very controllable we want
different task indices to correspond to
different coherent behaviors so the
intuition behind the method that I'm
going to describe is that different
skills different values of Z should
visit a different state space regions
not necessarily different goals but
different regions and this generalizes
the notion of goals so here's how we can
do it we're going to use a diversity
promoting reward function so when you
train your policy you're always going to
train it the same way you're gonna train
it with with RL maybe maximum entropy RL
but some kind of
reward maximizing thing maybe with an
entropy term and the thing that you get
to choose is its reward right so we're
going to train our policy to be the art
max of the sum expected reward and of
course we have many different Z's so
we'll sum that over all possible Z's the
choice that we have to make is the
choice of our and our R will depend on Z
so different tasks have different
rewards but of course we can't design
the manual we have to somehow acquire
them automatically so we'll make a very
simple choice will reward states that
are unlikely for other Z's we'll say you
get a big reward if you go to a state
that's very likely for the currency and
very unlikely for the other Z's and that
will encourage the Z's to specialize so
the way that you do this if you want to
think about how this condemned
mechanically is you train a classifier
you train a classifier that that
predicts P of Z given s what does P of Z
given s well Z is an integer s as a
state so you can treat diseases basic
categorical labels P of Z given s as a
classifier that classifies which integer
was fed into your policy that resulted
in visiting the state s so if I see you
going somewhere because somebody gave
you a command what I'm trying to guess
is what command were you given that
calls you to go over there so then you
can imagine this whole system the
training of the classifier the training
of the policy and so on as a loop where
you have your policy your agent it takes
actions those go to the environment
their environment responds with States
the policy at the beginning of the first
time so very of every episode is given a
skill an integer a Z and the state goes
to this discriminate of this classifier
which attempts to guess what Z was given
to the policy and there they're
colluding they're cooperating with each
other the policy is trying to do the
thing that makes the classifier get the
right answer and the classifier is
trying to look at what the policy did
and and try to guess the right answer so
now let's think about what this
interaction will actually do to the
behavior of the policy let's say that I
have only two values of C just for
simplicity so I have a green value and
blue value initially you have a random
policy and the and when you
you conditioning on green on your
conditioner on blue it kind of does the
same random stuff but of course just to
random chance
sometimes the green lines will be a
little bit further this way the blue
lines will be a little further this way
so when you train your classifier the
classifier will say I have no idea
what's going on but if you really want
me to draw a decision boundary I'm gonna
draw this one because you know there's a
little more green stuff over here a
little more blue stuff over here it
really has no idea but it's like if it's
saying like maybe this is like 51% this
is like 49% so there's just a little bit
of tiebreaker through random chance when
the policy gets to go again now the
policy is trying to help this classifier
it's saying oh you think that this is
51% green and this is 49% green ok I can
do that I can send more green stuff here
more blue stuff here and then the
classifier gets to go again and the
classifier will draw the line a little
more cleanly and then the policy gets to
go and we'll separate out even more and
so on eventually this process will cause
the policy and the classifier to agree
on a separation of the state space and
of course this is an example with two
skills but now imagine you did this with
like 2000 skills then you'd have
policies that go to all do you have
skills that go to all the different
places in the world and also avoid all
the different places and basically do
all all possible combinations of state
space region coverage ok any questions
about this method yes that's a really
interesting question yeah so the
question for those of you who didn't
hear is is it possible to do this with
some kind of meaningful latent features
I think that could be possible yeah so
you could imagine for example doing some
something where you impose structure on
disease you could for example instead of
having disease be integers you could
have them be vectors of categorical
variables almost like Electress of
attributes you could supervise some of
the Z's you can say well these entries
correspond to like these semantically
meaningful features the other interest
could correspond to whatever you want so
he could probably impose a lot more
structure on disease we've tried a
little bit of that but not very much I
can I can tell you a little bit after
the lecture if you want any other
questions yeah
right yeah yeah yeah so that so the
question was well I made a big deal out
of how goal reaching is not the same as
skills but now I'm telling you that
different skills correspond to different
states so so what's up the that's a very
good question and the answer is a little
subtle because while this is trying to
make different tasks correspond to
different states it's no longer trying
to make different tasks correspond to
different goals so you could have for
example a state visitation profile for
this blue line which is like avoid this
region and end up in this region so
that's a little bit more elaborate than
just reaching goals now there's there
are other versions of this kind of
method that could be formulated for
example you could imagine training your
classifier to predict Z naught condition
on a single state but conditional and
entire sequence of states then you have
non Markovian rewards which is a little
tough but then you would actually get
this thing to separate the policy into
all sorts of different trajectories
which would maybe be a little closer to
what your to what you might want there's
a subtlety here though which is that
different trajectories might also not be
exactly what you want cuz you can have
two trajectories that look very
different but achieve very similar
outcomes so there's a choice that you
have to make in fact people have
proposed variants on the subjective
there are a couple other papers I think
I have a citation of that somewhere see
what I have that ok so here there's a
citation to Gregor out all variational
in terms of control so if you check out
this paper of Ariel in terms of control
it actually proposed a slightly
different discriminator which is
conditioned on the current state and
like the last state or something and you
can do all sorts of combinations
conditioned on trajectories current
state future state whatever and they all
end up with so many different
definitions of what a task is ok any
other questions ok let's look at what
this thing does
so we can train it on everybody's
favorite half cheetah task I'm not sure
whether you guys have to do any of the
majokoi RL things in this course do you
know raise your hand if you know know
what how she does it doesn't mean
anything okay
so that half cheat is supposed to run
that's his goal in life but if you don't
know what the reward function perhaps
cheetah is and you just run this
unsupervised skill extraction method if
sometimes you get skills that run in a
very festive way sometimes you get
skills that actually run backwards it's
very easy to tell whether you're running
backwards or forwards so the
discriminator really likes that but
sometimes it'll also do like a weird
front flip because that's also very easy
to distinguish from running forward and
backwards so it basically tries to do
the most extreme things that are the
easiest to distinguish here is the ant
the ant kind of you know the ant has a
lot more different things that it could
do so it ends up doing these kind of
funny Wiggles where sometimes it'll walk
in like a letter S shape sometimes a
letter J shape so sort of walks in
different Wiggles if you run this on a
really simple tasks like Mountain car
mountain car is a pretty simple task
there's only so many things you could do
so usually you get one of the skills
extra corresponding just outright
solving tasks so this this skill is just
doing the task it's basically reaching
the goal the other skills are doing
other weird stuff like this one appears
to be trying to go as fast as possible
so something is actually working and the
skills are actually distinguishable from
one another you can also use this for
hair color L so you can train up some
skills for the cheetah and then you can
make the cheetah do hurdles by treating
the skills the different Z's as
different actions for higher level
policy the same with the ant you can
take the skills for the end and then
train a higher level policy that directs
the ants different places so these are
some learning curves for a hierarchical
version but perhaps for the purpose of
today's lecture one thing I do want to
make sure to cover is the connection
between this and all these other
information theoretic ideas that I
touched on so recall that our objective
is to maximize the expected value of our
reward and our reward is log P of Z
given s it turns out that this is also
maximizing mutual information but now
instead of goals you have Z's so it's
maximizing mutual information between Z
and s remember the mutual information is
the difference of two entropy the
entropy of Z minus the entropy of Z
given s this first term back when we had
goals was very hard now it's very easy
because these these are integers how do
you maximize the
B of Z will just pick your integers
uniformly at random if you pick them
uniformly at random that first term is
maximized so that's really easy it's
actually the second term that's hard and
the second term is of course minimized
by maximizing log P of Z given s if your
classifier is perfect then that second
term has zero as it has no entropy so
just make your classifier be really
really good conveniently enough that's
exactly what the whole method is doing
because the classifier is training
itself to be really good and the policy
is changing itself so the classifier is
an easier time classifying States so
this method is also doing mutual
information between Z and s where Z is
basically the replacement for goals now
ok so the last thing I'm going to talk
about and this is going to be quite
brief is a kind of an application of
this idea to meta learning so so far we
just talked about the unsupervised part
like how do you discover these different
skills but what if you actually want to
use this in a meta learning setting so I
don't think I need a quick summary well
you should all know what MIT IRL is
right so I could just skip this I think
if you don't you know if you haven't
been paying attention then maybe maybe
it's too late for that
but let's talk about something else
let's talk about the bad stuff let's
talk about meta overfitting which is
about as exciting as it sounds so meta
learning requires tasks distributions
and where do the TAS distributions come
from and meta learning well they come
from you right you have to build them if
you're doing reinforcement learning
maybe you figure it out that a good set
of tasks to meta train on is tasks that
require the amp to run in different
directions and if you were smart enough
to design those tasks to find rewards
for all of them and then use them for
meta training then you might be able to
adapt quickly to new tasks so you might
you know run something like mammal and
the end of some cool stuff where it runs
in place ready to go and as soon as
given even a tiny bit of reward for
running in a certain direction it
immediately figures it out but of course
that's only if you chose the right meta
training tasks when there are too few
meta training tasks you can meta overfit
which means that you're you become
really good at recalling your training
tasks but really bad at trying to figure
out new tasks the same as overfitting in
supervised learning you can have met
overfitting and meta learning so
specifying test distribution
can actually be a very delicate choice
and it can be quite difficult especially
for a reinforcement learning because
their tasks correspond to reward
functions which you're going to program
by hand so it'd be very nice to be able
to propose tasks automatically so that
you get as many tasks as you want and
avoid met overfitting of course you have
to propose them properly so that their
distribution has something in common
with it tasks that you want a test time
so you can imagine a kind of a pipeline
for unsupervised meta reinforcement
learning where you're given a particular
environment without a reward function
you automatically acquire some tasks
basically invent some things to do in
that environment and then meta learn on
those tasks so that then a test time
when somebody comes along and gives you
a reward function you can adapt very
quickly to that reward function without
having received inter reward functions
during meta training so what does it
mean to propose tasks well it means
making up some rewards R of s comma Z
for different tasks Z so different Z's
should have different rewards and meta L
just means train your model to maximize
the expectation with respect to all of
your tasks of the reward of the policy
after that policy has been updated on
that task so that's just the definition
of net RL so how can you propose tasks
well you can do exactly the thing that I
described before you can choose your R
of s comma Z to maximize the mutual
information between Z and s basically
using any of the techniques covered in
the lecture up to now and there's a
crucial difference here which is the
before the result was a policy
conditioned on the task before the
result was always like PI of a given s
comma G or PI of a given s comma Z but
if we're doing metal learning that's not
what we're after in metal learning what
we're after is a policy that can adapt
to rewards so if we use those tasks
format RL then what we get is not a PI
of a given s comma Z what we get is a
policy that can learn from rewards and
that's really nice because now we can
define new tasks for this thing just by
defining a reward we don't even have to
know what the Z's mean so this basic
idea does actually work so this is an
experiment that uses the this skill you
know mutual information between s comma
Z method called the diversities all you
need or Dian I in and unsupervised in
that RL pipeline and what these
comparisons show is the green one shows
the performance ad adaptation time so
there's a meta testing where the meta
training was done using task proposals
using that mutual information method the
red line shows RL from scratch and the
blue line that's a pretty funny one that
actually shows a setting where the meta
learning was done by proposing random
tasks the random tasks are proposed by
by initializing the discriminator with
random weights so it's sort of a random
shopping of the space the interesting
thing about this is that even the random
proposals actually worked decently well
in some cases like they work well for
this simple 2d navigational task they
kind of worked decently well for the and
they don't seem to work so well for the
cheetah for some reason the Dian ones
are a little more consistent but the
main point is that this kind of
unsupervised proposals can actually gave
you some decently meaningful medal learn
models so this is kind of potentially a
viable way to address the met
overfitting issue okay
well that's a further lecture I'd be
happy to take any questions from you
guys about either the last part the
unsupervised men are all or anything
that preceded it so if you have any
questions now is the time to ask yeah
yeah that's a really good question so
the question was I picked the number of
skills well I didn't pick a Ben
Eisenbach dicted so that's my excuse
somewhat arbitrarily is there a better
way to do it I don't know we did try
something that tossed seem pretty
obvious we just use a continuous space
of skills that really didn't work we're
not sure why we also tried somewhat less
obvious things like using a
combinatorial space of skills so if you
instead of having an integer you might
have a vector of binary values so if you
have you know thirty-two binary values
you can have 2 to the 32nd power
different skills still a discrete set
but a very large number that actually
works but I don't know how to select
that number and
[Music]
right yeah this is a this is a very
complex question that I could probably
give you you know maybe like a 20 30
minute answer but I'll give you the
short answer you can get well there's a
two-part short answer one part is you
can get meaningful behavior out of
seemingly contradictory objectives there
are actually many more examples that I
could give you after the lecture if you
like so that's a thing that happens and
this isn't the only case where it
happens but in terms of trying to
reconcile the relationships between
these different techniques something
that I might actually recommend is a
paper by mark belle mère called unifying
count based exploration and trinsic
motivation which discusses us in a
little bit more detail I don't think he
covers the the model error version of
intrinsic motivation in a lot of detail
but he does talk a lot about the log p
of s versus the counts and so on and
that might be a starting point to try to
understand how these things can be
reconciled
it seems like makes notice mr. RAL where
you're kind of partitioning the state
space but right so the question was
Ken's can something like this mutual
information diversity method be applied
to general unstructured data so
clustering does exactly this so if you
imagine doing like e you know Gaussian
mixture model or k-means clustering it
that's exactly exactly what it's doing
right can it learn tasks that is a more
complex question I mean you could
imagine clustering as learning tasks
like when when you cluster the space you
can say predict the cluster from the it
from the data points so that's a task in
fact that would probably be the closest
analog actually because if your
classifiers doing you know P of Z given
s then if you do clustering you do P of
Z given X that's that's the closest
analog I think you can probably do more
than that but I don't know it's a good
idea any other questions
you might need a couple of days it might
need a couple of days yeah so the
question was essentially how can we do
better than just optimizing for the
worst case in very complex environments
we're optimizing for the worst case
would take forever basically where there
are jillion things you could do the
two-part answer one is us a very lame
answer which is that this state a state
distribution matching formulation of
reinforcement learning kind of aims to
do exactly that it assumes that you're
given some distribution
yeah yeah right so how do you actually
get that distribution that's a really
good question and I don't really know
and I think that question also gets at
something a bit deeper it's really kind
of a design question it's like what's
the right way to communicate these
things or what's the right way to you
know should you use data should you have
some communication channel but one other
answer that i that i that i want to give
here which is maybe a little bit of
lateral thinking on this topic is that
perhaps it's not so unreasonable to try
to learn all the things if you're doing
a little bit better than just density
estimation because what you can do is
you can figure out that even though you
haven't broken every single dish yet
having broken one of the dishes you can
kind of guess what's gonna happen if you
break all the others so if you don't
have to break every single dish before
deciding that you've mastered the dish
breaking skill and move on to something
more productive so perhaps having this
thing be somehow aware of your
capability to generalize might actually
cover the space without like physically
covering the space okay should we wrap
up
[Applause]